thank you for asking that the most
interesting session for me today was a
tough with a session on climate
adaptation adaptation to climate change
and the question was framed around how
we solve for a global emissions problem
and for me that's a question for 2050
because the problem right now is that
the human race is not prepared to adapt
to the changes that were already
experiencing and climate change so the
debate needs to change from mitigation
in spending 10 12 trillion dollars
Bloomberg estimates will spend 10
trillion dollars mainly in the developed
world to build wind farms solar and
biofuels and in the meantime we're
having a catastrophe every month and
ninety percent of that is due to
weather-related events so people are
suffering the need for focusing on
adaptation beginning to invest in under
the themes of coastal protection water
scarcity food security in in the context
of droughts those are the issues we need
to start working like and and the
session got that we're starting to turn
in a corner we're not talking about
turning back the hands of time now
starting to say let's solve the problem
that people and the problems that people
are experiencing today and that's high
concentration of people living very
vulnerable cities that require help and
resilience and so the mood has changed
at Davos this year from the last two
years when I've been here adaptation is
no longer during word and people are
moving and it's great to see thank you